kelly clarkson the new season of the
voice premieres on monday and as you
know look
kelly never holds back and when we talk
to her about her personal life
she was very candid about how she's been
dealing with the heartbreak
of her painful divorce
i don't know how anybody i'll just be
real with you goes through grief
like divorce any kind of grief any kind
of loss without having an outlet
i have written like 60 songs like
it's like an insane amount of getting it
out yes
kelly will be going there on her new
album diving into her divorce from
husband of seven years
brandon blackstock
[Music]
there's a lot of questions that i just
have to answer before releasing it
it's one of those things you have to
talk about like what are you willing
to put out there the mom of six-year-old
river and four-year-old remington filed
for divorce in june
and says listening to fellow coach john
legend's new album
actually helped her get through
not it i literally was going through the
worst moments of my like emotional
life and me hearing that during this
time was like
okay this is not hopeless music has a
way of just like healing you what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger
now kelly's focused on the future and
she's back as a coach on the voice for
her seventh time
the win count going into season 20 blake
has seven
kelly three john one and nick
zero he's certainly the hungriest
starving for a win
today nick drops the big news he's
releasing a new solo album
space man is out march 12th and he told
me he
is coming for blake this season make
blake cry
it's gonna be a lot of fun for me lauren
i don't know if you watched the super
bowl
they were referring to tom brady as the
greatest
of all time and and i thought it was
interesting that he has won seven
championships and i
have won seven championships so there's
something incredibly comical about
blake comparing himself to tom brady
that's just
well last season blake was beat by
fiance gwen stefani
but she's sitting this one out blake is
totally on his own
she does not help me out because i'm
still the competition i'm sleeping with
the enemy here
nick what about you does priyanka help
out yeah that must be tough blake i feel
really bad for you there um yeah she
does priyanka helps me out she's been a
fan of the show since it started
like you're looking like you have
something to say about that i actually
had nick on mute that entire time
[Laughter]
well here is something that nick and
blake do have in common
blake hosted snl in 2015 and this
weekend
it's nick's turn there he is all massed
[Music]
up